JEFF DAVIS: Welcome to the
Google Cloud Platform Education
series.
My name is Jeff Davis,
and in this session,
we'll discuss adding
machine learning
into your applications.
We'll be running a moderated
Q&A during the session,
so feel free to ask
questions using the Ask
Your Question field at
the bottom of your screen.
Let's get started.
We'll begin by doing
a series of demos.
We'll show the capabilities of
Google's machine learning APIs,
and we'll show how you can
access those through simple web
interfaces or
through incorporating
them using client libraries
in your own applications.
Then we'll move on
and talk about machine
learning as a whole on
the Google Cloud platform.
We'll talk about use of the
APIs and their capabilities
and pricing.
We'll also talk about Google
Cloud Machine Learning
Engine, which is the general
purpose platform on which you
build, train, deploy, and
query your own machine learning
models.
We'll finish up by
talking about how
to get more information
after this session,
how to evaluate the
opportunities that you have
for using Google's
machine learning features
in your own products,
and again, we'll
be doing Q&A
throughout the session.
So let's start with some demos.
We're going to
switch over to here,
and I'm going to show you
the capabilities of each
of the machine learning vision--
or each of the machine learning
APIs through the simple web
interface that you
can find online.
So we'll start with
the Vision API.
The Vision API allows you
to very easily identify
characteristics and content
information about pictures,
so let's take a look at that.
You'll notice, here,
I can select a photo.
I'm going to pick a photo
off of my hard drive,
and we'll drag this
into the web browser.
Now, this is making a machine
learning API call to the Vision
API, and you can see the
whole range of characteristics
that this API can give
you information about.
So it's analyzing
the person's face,
and it's trying to
identify is the person
happy, sad, angry, surprised.
You'll notice there's not a
whole lot of positives here.
We basically have found he
doesn't seem to be super happy,
doesn't seem to be angry,
surprised, or whatever.
If we look at labels, we
can see that it's then
a pretty good job of
identifying appropriate labels
for the photo, so we can
see that it's a person.
We can see that it's
probably a surgeon.
Not sure where arm comes in, but
physician sounds pretty good.
You can use this,
therefore, to actually go
through a range of
images, identify
the content of the images,
and take appropriate actions.
I'll show you an
application of some
of these things in my own demo
applications in just a sec.
You can get properties.
So for instance, this
tells you what colors
are used in the photo.
So if you had an
application, for instance,
that was going to scan
the internet for pictures
of your product, and you wanted
pictures that had certain color
schemes because those would look
good in your current marketing
campaign's layouts, you
could easily do that.
Safe Search basically
identifies whether or not
the content might
be inappropriate,
so is it adult content?
Is it violent?
Is it spoof content?
This is content where it's
sort of sarcastic in nature
and might not be appropriate
for your applications.
And then the JSON here,
this is the actual response
of all of the
characteristics that
get returned to you
by the Vision API.
So what does this all have
to do with machine learning?
Well, what Google
is doing is they
are taking tons and
tons and tons of images
and corresponding
labeling information,
and they're training
a model specifically
at identifying the information
about faces, labels,
properties,
inappropriate content,
and so forth on images.
So this is a very
purposeful API,
but it's one with wide
and common applications.
Lots of applications
could make use of this,
and so they make it available.
If we look at the
Speech API, again, you
have a similar demonstration.
Notice the Speech API can work
in a variety of languages.
I'm going to use
English, and I'm just
going to speak to
the web browser.
We need to plan a
Q1 business review,
and our top priority
for Q2 is a proof
of concept on the Professional
Edition and an upgrade.
You can see that it
has actually taken--
it's transcribed
what I had to say,
and this would be super
helpful, for instance,
if you incorporated this into
applications that your customer
success managers or
your sales rep use.
It's hard enough to get
those folks to enter
good data into your CRM system.
This makes it easier.
They can just talk
into an application,
have it transcribe, and
automatically add it.
Let's look at the
Cloud Translation API.
So I'm going to switch this
from English to Chinese.
I can't type
Chinese, so it's not
going to make a lot of
sense, and I'm actually
going to choose to
translate this into Spanish.
So then if I say, we need to
schedule a business review,
you'll notice that it
translates it on the fly,
although I should
spell things correctly.
And the primary goal for Q2 is
to perform a proof of concept
on Pro Edition and
arrange an up-sell.
Now, you'll notice that there
are two different translations
available.
There's the Standard Edition
and the Premium Edition.
The Premium Edition is intended
for larger blocks of text,
and rather than doing sort of
a word by word or short phrase
by a short phrase
translation, it's
looking at the context
of the overall document,
and is able to use
large quantities of text
and the context in order to
make more intelligent decisions
about its translation.
The fourth API that I'll show
you is the cloud language--
Cloud Natural Language
API, and what this does
is it allows you to enter text,
and it will analyze the text
and sort of draw three
different sets of insights.
So you'll notice,
the first is what's
called entity extraction.
So when it looks
at the text, it's
able to identify Google
is an organization,
Android is a consumer
good, Sundar is a person,
the Consumer Electronics
Show is an event,
so it's able to actually go
through and identify entities
and then link to
information on the internet
about those entities.
On the other hand, if I said,
I really liked Google Hangouts
better than anything else.
It was clearly as good
as Zoom, for instance.
You'll notice it's
able to extract
that Zoom is an
organization, Google Hangouts
is a consumer good--
anything is sort of
interesting, so it's
not perfect, but pretty good.
Now, in addition to being
able to extract entities,
which is really
useful, for instance,
if you want to scan a bunch
of tweets about your product
and find out what
other products are
mentioned in the same tweets.
That way, you get a better
idea of what your customers
consideration sets are.
You might also want to know how
they feel about your product,
so we take the same
sentence, and we
have the Natural Language
API do sentiment analysis.
And you can see that the
overall sentiment is positive,
so this goes from
negative 1 for really,
really negative to positive 1
for really, really positive.
So this is a 0.4, which is
good, and this number gives you
a strength of the feeling.
So it's really good,
but you can be sort of,
eh, it's really good, but
it's not that important.
Or it could be really good,
and it's really important.
So you'll notice that the first
sentence was a 0.4 and a 0.4,
and the second sentence was
actually slightly better.
Now, if I said it was
almost as good as Zoom,
and we analyze
that, you'll notice
continues to be really strong.
If you say, I hated this.
My video was grainy,
and my session
kept getting
disconnected probably
because I was hijacking
my neighbor's wifi--
not that anybody would
actually do that.
Again, if we look
at the sentiment,
you'll notice overall
sentiment is negative,
and in fact, the word hate
clearly denotes really
strong dissatisfaction, also
fairly strong overall magnitude
of sentiment.
The third category of analysis
that the Natural Language
API performs for you is
a syntactical analysis.
So this actually
does a bunch of stuff
that's a little
beyond my expertise,
but it's able to
sort of indicate
how the various words are
related to one another
and what parts of speech
each one is, and so forth.
So this could be useful, but
the first two are the ones
that I've seen more typically
used within applications
by the customers
that I work with.
So obviously, the
functionality is really cool.
It's great and all,
but you can't really
do business by going to each of
these special purpose machine
learning APIs and working
interactively with the UIs.
So what you really
want to do is you
want to have your developers
be able to consume
these insights from the machine
learning APIs within programs.
So what we're
going to do here is
I'm going to shrink this down,
and we'll shrink this down,
and I've got a couple
of examples here.
So you'll notice I've got
some code in my Finder window.
I'm going to actually look at
that code in my code editor
here, and so the first one that
I'm using is the Speech API.
So the Speech API--
I'm using an example that
Google has provided us,
and I'm using the Google
Cloud Python client libraries.
And so what I'm going to
do here is, in Quick Start,
you can see that I'm
going to import speech
from Google Cloud library.
I'm going to create
a speech client.
I'm going to open
a file, and this
is a recorded file that's
very much like the content
that I spoke into the web page.
And I'm going to open the file,
read it in as an audio sample,
and then I'm going to ask the
speech client to actually do
asynchronous recognition,
extract the content out
of the audio file,
and transcribe that.
So let's see if that works.
That's not the one we want.
That's-- let's see if
this is what we want.
That's the image API, so we'll
come back to that in a second.
So this-- let's run it,
and if all goes well,
we should get
output that contains
the transcript of the audio
file that I recorded earlier.
And so you'll see,
the transcript
says we need to schedule
and delivering--
I didn't speak as
clearly as I might of--
a Q1 business review.
Primary goal in Q2 is
to do a proof of concept
and close the opportunity
for the pro upgrade.
OK, not bad.
Now, again, I'm doing this
from the command line.
I haven't incorporated
it into a full app yet,
but this shows you
how straightforward
it is to actually incorporate.
So if we go to the Vision API,
we have a similar example.
So the Quick Start
here basically says
let's import the vision library
instead of the speech library.
Let's create a vision client.
Let's find the wakeupcat
file, and let's
feed it to the
Vision API and see
what information we get back.
And specifically, I want
to look at the labels.
I don't need to see
all the other stuff.
I just want to see the labels.
So let's go back and I'm going
to close the speech client,
and let's actually
open the wakeupcat
so you can see what
the image looks like.
There's our cat, and
we're going to feed
this image to the Vision API
and see what it has to say.
So takes a moment or two
to run, and it comes back,
and it gives you the labels.
This is similar to
the set of labels
that were displayed in the web
UI during the first example
that I gave.
So this identifies the picture
as having a cat, the cat
being a mammal, the cat
having whiskers, the cat being
a small to medium sized
cat as opposed to a big cat
like a lion or a tiger.
This could be a cat
like mammal, so that
would be like a
links or something
like that, something that isn't
a cat but looks like a cat.
And then animal shelter
is the last one,
and I'm not sure which
components made it
look like the animal shelter.
Perhaps the industrial blinds
in the background, but probably
lower level of confidence
in that prediction.
OK, these are great, again,
little code examples.
But, Jeff, I want to
see something meatier.
I want to see something
actually live and running
and show all of Google's
machine learning
prowess being brought to bear
in a real business problem.
OK, so let's take a look
at a live application.
This application is a
customer success application.
It's used by a post-sales
customer facing team
to monitor customer's
engagement and experiences
with the product, and
to intervene proactively
to help drive better outcomes
for the customer and better
up-sell and renewal for
the product, and so forth.
And the product at hand is a
video conferencing product.
People do calls.
When they're done with the
call, they can leave a rating,
but they can also
leave a text message,
a certain chunk of feedback.
And we want to be able
to analyze whether or not
that feedback is
positive or negative,
and we want to be able to deal
with feedback in a variety
of different languages.
So what I'm going to do is
go to the Comments page,
and what we have here
is a proof of concept.
We have a list of comments.
These comments are provided
in different languages.
So you notice the first
comments in English,
the second comment is in
French, the third comment
is in Spanish, the fourth
comment is in Chinese,
and the fifth comment
is in Swahili.
So clearly, we have customers
all around the world.
Now, if I were an English-only
customer success manager,
and I was just looking at
the raw feedback provided
by customers, I would have no
idea which 4/5 of my comments
meant.
But notice here, I am
getting the original comment,
and then I'm also getting
an English translation,
so this is saying it was good,
the audio was a bit squeaky.
This was saying, I was
disappointed that there's
no support for Linux.
Obviously, happy camper
with this comment.
Another happy camper here.
Additionally, not only
does this translate
from the original
language to English,
it also performs a sentiment
analysis and color codes
that so I can
easily take a look.
I can see, for instance,
that this clearly
seems to be a strongly
happy customer.
This customer is all right.
This customer is not at
all happy, and so forth.
Now, again, this is
just a proof of concept.
It would be less useful to
have an individual looking
at this interactively
than to be performing,
say, a mass analysis, where
you take all of the comments
from all of your users
over the last 30 days,
and you aggregate them,
looking at sentiment analysis,
and that you identify what
percentage of comments
are strongly negative versus
sort of medium versus strongly
positive.
And you can perform
outreach to customers
that are strongly positive in
order to cultivate champions,
whereas you could reach
out to unhappy customers
to try to do account recovery or
solve whatever problem they're
running into.
Implementing this was just as
easy as the quick little demos
that I gave you previously.
So if I go in, and
I look here, you
can see this is where I
put the sample comments.
And up at the top, I've
imported two client libraries,
so I've imported the translate
library from the Google Cloud
client, and I've imported
the language library.
And then I make a translate
client and a language client,
and then to do the
translation, you
can see the first thing that
I do is detect the language.
So I don't know ahead of time
what language the comment is
in, and I have to tell the
Translation API what language
to translate from and to.
So the first thing that
I do is I detect that,
and then I actually
do the translation,
and then I'm going to
output the translation.
Similarly, I used the
natural language client
to create a document from
the text that was provided.
Now, you'll notice I'm using the
translated the English content.
For some languages,
you can actually
do this with the
native language.
French, for instance--
native detection
with the natural language
API is not available,
so I translated
everything into English.
And then I do a
sentiment analysis,
and I'm going to use the
sentiment score to output.
Now, obviously, there isn't
any sort of error handling.
You're going to want to-- if
you were doing production code,
it would be more robust.
But this gives you a sense
that, in 10 or 15 lines of code,
I am now tapping into this
highly trained, ever evolving
API for language
and for translation,
and I get the benefits directly
in my application with very
little real development time.
This legitimately took me from--
the first time I did this,
this took me less than an hour
to read the documentation,
figure out the APIs,
write the code, and
start consuming.
So four different APIs.
We have Vision,
Speech, Translation,
and Natural Language,
and these all
can be very easily incorporated
into your applications
tomorrow with a
small amount of code.
So really, you just
have to think about what
use cases you can leverage.
Now, let's say that
you need something more
specific to your environment.
So Vision is nice,
Speech is nice,
but let's say you want
to do damage assessment.
You want to look
at images of roofs,
and based on the
damage to the roof,
you want to identify
what the cost is
going to be to repair that.
This is being done by
insurance companies now.
They actually will fly drones.
The drone will go up, fly
over, take video footage,
that footage gets uploaded
to a machine learning model.
The machine learning
model can then actually
do estimates on how long
it will take to repair
and how much it
will cost to repair.
In order to do
that, obviously, you
can't use one of these
very general purpose
machine learning APIs.
You would have to
build your own model.
I'm not going to demo that
because, if you actually look--
let's do Cloud ML Engine Demo.
We've got some samples here.
If we did the introductory
example for Cloud ML Engine--
so this is building-- taking
a dataset from the census
and building a model
that will predict,
based on census demographics,
what your earnings will be.
I just want to show you
real quick what's entailed
in setting up this model.
So you'll notice this article
goes on for a little while.
It's not actually terribly
hard to make this intro work,
but it would take significantly
longer than we have today
to get everything built,
to train the models,
to test them, and then
get them up to speed.
A big part of this,
beyond what you
would see in this introduction,
is that you actually
have to collect the right data.
You have to sanitize the data,
You have to format the data.
The quality and quantity of
your data is really critical.
If I were to demo it,
what I would probably
do is do another demo here,
and what you would want to do
is actually predict churn.
So what customer success teams
are really, really interested
in is looking at these
renewals and finding
who's coming up for
renewals that you might not
get a full renewal on.
And that's kind of the holy
grail of customer success,
is being able to identify
potential churn candidates
and then intervene
in enough time
that you can make it go away.
Clearly, Google
doesn't have a model
already created and serving for
my particular customer base.
I would have to create my own.
I would also need a
relatively good set of data
from a relatively significant
number of customers.
So since this is a demo, I
don't have all of that at hand,
but I think you get the point.
So hopefully, this
has really begun
sort of getting you
thinking about how you could
use either the canned
APIs or your own models
in your applications.
So lets talk a little bit more
about the general capabilities
of machine learning across
Google Cloud Platform.
So in the bottom
row here, you have
the machine learning
offerings, and the four
items on the right, you
should be quite familiar with.
There's the Vision
API, the Speech API,
the Natural Language API, and
the Cloud Translation API.
Google also just did
a Video Insights API,
where you can
actually now extract
information similar to what
you get out of the Vision
API for still images.
You can actually do
this out of videos now.
And then on the left is the
Cloud Machine Learning Engine,
so the Google Cloud
Machine Learning Engine,
which is quite a mouthful,
but its also quite
a handful of technology.
Basically it uses the TensorFlow
model development framework,
and it automatically provisions
and builds the clusters
necessary to train your model.
And then you can deploy your
model and run predictions
against the model.
The top row here is a bunch
of tools used in big data
and analytics workloads.
And remember, I said that the
care and feeding of your data
that you feed into your
machine learning models
is absolutely critical.
And so you're going to want
to leverage big query data
flow, data proc, data lab in
order to collect your data,
organize your data,
sanitize your data,
and get it ready to feed into
the Cloud Machine Learning
Engine.
So a few details about the APIs
and about the machine learning
engine.
So the Cloud Vision
API is accessible
through a simple REST API.
It can detect labels,
logos, landmarks, and faces,
so an example that we might
use in my customer success
application is I might
want to actually find
all of the photos of my
product in certain verticals.
And so what I want to do
is I want to find our logo,
but I then also
want to get labels
that indicate whether it's
an industrial environment
or a medical environment
or a social environment.
And that way, I can actually
extract those photos
and put them in collateral
aimed at those verticals.
It can do OCR, so you can
obviously extract the text
content out of the images.
If you run any sort of a
platform where customers
are creating and sharing
content with other customers,
you clearly are
concerned about what
gets posted because you don't
want inappropriate content--
this is either violent content
or things like nudity--
to poison the well
in your community.
So you can actually
run all of your stuff
through the Google Cloud Vision
API before it gets submitted,
and you can use this to
take appropriate action
if inappropriate
content happens.
And obviously, all
the image attributes,
so again, this is if you
want to find all of the files
in your giant photo
repository that
meet certain conditions in terms
of color scheme, for instance.
The pricing for making use of
the Vision API is $1.50 per
1,000 units, and you get an
initial allotment of units
for free.
The second API that we talked
about was the Speech API.
The Speech API
supports recognition
of up to 80 plus languages.
It can be real
time are recorded,
so we showed you
real time when I
was speaking into
the website, and you
can build that
functionality fairly easily.
Google actually makes
a quiet library.
It's optimized to detect
the active speaker,
even when there is
surrounding noise.
This is really important
because, very often,
when somebody's speaking, it's
not in an enclosed studio,
but rather they may
be out on the street,
they may be in an open
floor plan office,
and you want to
be able to extract
the speech from
the primary speaker
and ignore the background noise
and background conversations.
If you are in an
environment where
you have a lot of
technical jargon or words
that would not be common
in everyday speech,
you can actually provide a word
or phrase hints to the API.
So you can say, for instance,
that gas and energy terminology
that isn't in
everyday conversation
might be common in the audio
inputs that you're providing,
and so you provide a list
of those phrases and words,
and it's more likely that
they will be recognized.
And like the Vision
API, it can actually
identify inappropriate
content and filter that out.
Pricing for the Google
Cloud Speech API
is 6/10 of a cent
per 15 seconds,
with the first 60
minutes being free.
The Google Cloud Translation
API can work with a hundred
different languages.
As I noted in the example that
I gave in the customer success
application, it can do
automatic language detection.
The model is being consistently
upgraded by Google,
so it's constantly
getting better.
You start with a
maximum quota in terms
of the number of characters
that you can spend,
but you can easily
adjust this up
if you do large
amounts of translation.
And as I noted, there
is a Premium Edition,
and the Premium Edition is
less for translating phrases
in short quantities of text,
and rather for translating
large blocks of text.
And it is able to use the
context throughout the block
to do sort of better
narrative translation.
Pricing here starts at $20 per
million characters translated.
The Google Cloud Natural
Language API, as we saw,
can do three types of
insight extraction.
It can pull out the
entities and identify
who those entities are.
It can do sentiment analysis,
which is the most common use
that I've seen in the field.
And it can do
syntactical analysis.
It supports multiple languages.
Not all languages of origination
are supported, so for instance,
French isn't.
But you can try it
in your own language,
and if you don't-- if it doesn't
work in the default language
that you would prefer, you
can actually translate it
to English and do that.
Pricing starts at $1
per million units,
with the first 5,000
units being free.
Now these again are
Google's canned models.
They're heavily trained.
They're really, really strong,
but they are general purpose.
They don't necessarily solve the
problem that you are tackling,
so you can build
your own models.
Now, the way that Google
has built their models
is they have fed large
quantities of data,
so an example here would
be training the Vision API.
You feed it a bunch of images,
and with each of these images,
you provide an
appropriate label.
You run a very large,
well-crafted dataset
through a mathematical
model, and once you've
trained it, what's happening is
the machine learning process,
in this case,
running an ML Engine,
it's going to continue to
tweak this mathematical model
until it has a very
high probability
that if you put in a cat,
what's going to come out
is the label cat.
Now, obviously, you
probably don't want
to replicate the Vision API.
You can just pay
Google by the image,
but what I would do here,
for say the customer success
application, is
instead of images,
I would give descriptions
of customers.
So for every customer
of our product,
when did they buy, how
big a company they are,
how much did they buy
initially, how much have
they used the product, is usage
going up, is usage going down.
And I would give
as many features
as I think are likely
relevant, and then I
would indicate whether or
not these customers renewed
or scaled back their
purchases or up-sold.
And the goal is
to create a model
that, instead of
spitting out cat, instead
when I give it a new customer
with a bunch of features
describing their interactions
with our company and product,
they give me out a
label that indicates
high probability of renewal
or high probability of churn.
To do this, you would--
again, you would use Cloud
Machine Learning Engine.
You define your
models in TensorFlow,
which is a machine learning
model development framework.
This is a portable framework,
so you can develop your models
and run them on Cloud
Machine Learning Engine,
but you can also take
them and run them
on whatever other
infrastructure you want.
The Machine Learning Engine
is tightly integrated
with other Google
services, so it's
easy to pull in data from Google
Cloud Storage, for instance.
Or you could do a bunch of
your analysis in BigQuery
and dump the results out into
your Machine Learning Engine
project.
They have a feature
called HyperTuning.
So hyper parameters
are parameters
that are not feature
related on individual items,
but rather how deep do you
want the neural network to be.
How many leaves do you want?
HyperTune will automatically
adjust those parameters for you
and find what choices are going
to give you the highest level
of accuracy in your models.
It's quite scalable.
So you can go ahead-- if you
do that demo that I showed you,
the example that
Google gives you,
you start by doing training
with a single instance.
But you can scale that up
and do distributed training.
You can train your model
using a single instance.
using 10 instances.
You can train your model
using 75 instances, and so on.
And so this allows you to
feed more data into your model
training faster.
I mentioned that the
models are portable,
and again, the whole training
and deployment and use
of your model is a
fully managed service.
You don't have to worry
about acquiring hardware.
You don't even have to
worry about spinning up
individual VMs.
You simply turn the dial,
say you want to train,
and Google will
automatically scale out
the resources as necessary.
Pricing for ML Engine starts
at $0.49 per node hour
for training and $0.40 per
node hour for prediction,
plus there's an additional $0.10
per 1,000 predictions charge.
Again, if you want to
have an idea of the cost
that your project may
incur ahead of time,
go and use the
pricing calculator.
So whether it's APIs or building
your own models on Cloud ML
Engine, you want to
think where can I
start using machine learning
to make my applications better,
and there's tons and
tons of applications.
I was at Next last week,
and as I listened and sat in
on the talks about
machine learning,
I kept thinking of
all of the software
that I've developed
over the last five
years and all the places that
I could use machine learning.
So sentiment analysis on
comments, churn prediction,
up-sell prediction,
conversion predictions--
all tremendous things.
So we had done a little
bit of data science
at my last company,
where we determined
that if a customer got to
one hour of calls every day
for every box that they
had purchased, that they
would be a customer forever.
Their usage kept going
up, and they would renew.
And we found that any customer
who didn't hit that milestone
would actually churn, and it
was very high correlation,
so it was fairly
good predictability.
But with this, it would
have been a lot easier.
That was a lot of manual
work in building processes
on local resources.
With this, we would be much
better off feeding as much data
in with a bunch of
features and having
it build the model for us.
So after today's session, as
you begin to play with the APIs,
or you begin to explore
building, training, deploying,
and using your own
models, where do you
look for additional information?
As always, you
start with search.
So if you type in Google
Cloud and the API name,
then you're going to get
information about the Vision
API or the Translation API.
If you type in Google
Cloud ML and a topic, then
you'll get information about the
machine learning capabilities
with Cloud ML Engine.
So for instance, one of
the things that Google does
is they support the use of GPUs
for training your models using
Cloud ML Engine, so if you
type in Google Cloud ML GPU,
you'll get articles that
tell you how to do it,
how much it costs,
stuff like that.
Again, you have sort of
the standard organization
of documentation
for Cloud ML Engine,
so you've got the six quadrants.
You've got a Quick Start,
which that's super quick.
That's just basically
installing TensorFlow
and being able to do something
very, very, very basic.
Then you have the how-to
guides and the tutorials,
and this is where
you're going to get
into that relatively
lengthy walkthrough
and some other better examples.
The documentation
for the APIs is
a little different than this,
but again, if you just search,
it'll take you directly
to the articles
that you're looking for.
So that's it for this session.
Thanks so much for joining us.
I hope you found it
interesting, and you're
inspired to incorporate
machine learning capabilities
into your own applications.
We'll be sending you an email
with a link to a code lab,
and you can use that to get
some hands-on experience
with machine
learning capabilities
on Google Cloud Platform.
We'd love your feedback, so
feel free to provide feedback
through the UI on your
screen and thanks very much.